as you may know AT&T is trying to buy
Time Warner for the tidy little sum of
85 billion dollars that's not news we've
talked about that before when the news
broke of that at least attempted sale
the news is that the Justice Department
has now sued to block that purchase and
this could be one of the biggest
antitrust cases in decades and it's
particularly newsworthy because usually
antitrust cases are attempt to stop
mergers of two of the same type of
company two media companies for example
and in this case the AT&T Time Warner
purchase or merger is a
telecommunications company trying to buy
a media and entertainment company and
trying to block those types of mergers
or acquisitions I guess to say is is
it's less common territory for courts
and it's really putting some
progressives and also Democratic elected
officials in an interesting place
because generally speaking the left
wants to prevent unfair and and sort of
obscene accumulations of market power
through these mega mergers progressives
want antitrust legislation and forced as
needed as as would be as designed I
guess is the term I'm looking for and
the issue of course is that CNN is owned
by Time Warner and all of this is
happening after the Trump Jeff Sessions
Justice Department has been very
critical of CNN and you have to wonder
could this be part of an attempt to
merely hurt CNN which we know President
Trump doesn't like right is this lawsuit
to try to stop this merger acquisition
an act of political retribution against
CNN and we may find out because AT&T
says that it's going to take the lawsuit
as an opportunity take the court process
as an opportunity to try and discover
and reveal communications that may have
taken place between the White House and
antitrust officials and that it could
potentially uncover political motivation
now if they're smart they wouldn't have
email records of the Trump White House
saying hey let's try to screw with CNN
but we know that the Trump
administration has a pretty extensive
track record of putting really sketchy
stuff into email the entire Russian
lawyer situation comes to mind
so if political motivation over this
lawsuit were uncovered the argument
would be that Donald Trump is
effectively of abusing his power as
president to make a political attack
against the private sector which is not
something that conservatives usually are
on board with 18 C's general counsel
their attorney made a comment that I
read and I really felt very conflicted
about it
David McAtee the second
who's a tnt's general counsel said
today's Department of Justice lawsuit is
a radical and inexplicable departure
from decades of antitrust precedent
vertical mergers like this one are
routinely approved because they benefit
consumers without removing any
competitor from the market we see no
legitimate reason for our merger to be
treated differently let's keep that on
the screen for a moment and analyze a
couple of the individual sentences it's
true that this lawsuit is a departure
from precedent these mergers typically
are approved it's it's completely
accurate when David McAtee the second
says that these are routinely approved
mergers it's not clear at all though
that they benefit consumers the way he
argues and in principle it would be
great to clamp down on these mega
mergers because they aren't good for
consumers but if the reason is a
political one that Trump wants to hurt
CNN then as progressives do we have to
be against it because it's a form of
government corruption or do we need to
be for it because it is a mechanism
through which we are supposed to prevent
this obscene and massive accumulation of
market power the mergers allow companies
like AT&T and Time Warner to raise
prices to suppress competition it's
really bad it's something we've been
talking about for years but at the same
time a personal vendetta by Donald Trump
can't be allowed to serve as the sort of
catalyst for blocking the merger since
we know that Republican administrations
and right
leanin Justice Department's like the one
we have right now are usually pretty
friendly to these types of mergers and
the White House can't be playing
favorites kind of a complex situation
for progressives which side should they
should we be on send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter reach me email however
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership